- It's the kind of wine that
makes you drunk before you realize it.
- I don't think I've ever
had American champagne.
- My expectations are
just like everything else
more processed, family
friendly version of the drink.
- Fast and processed.
- It just tastes like Alcohol with bubbles
and a little bit like champagne.
- I've had some really nice one,
but the complexity of the taste
is not as developed as it is with
European wines.
Especially, French.
- I do have to say it is a crime
to drink champagne
in anything else that's not a flute.
- To me it looks to bubbly.
- It look like an apple juice with bubble.
- Right off the bat it
smells like white wine.
- The color is pretty nice.
It's not to yellow, to sugary,
and it's not to clear,
but you would feel it's sparkling water.
- Should we go for it?
- Ok, lets try it.
- (French word)
- Yea, white wine.
White wine with bubbles.
- It's sweet.
It's bubbly.
- Mm Hm
You can feel it in your tongue.
- Really sugary.
- (laughs) Yea
- I mean, I'd still drink it.
- (laughs) Alright, here you go.
- It remind me of
champormene a little bit.
- Champormene, that's
exactly what we have.
- Yeah
- Which is for kids.
It's like a apple juice
with bubbles.
- But no alcohol.
- It tastes a little bit
like that.
But you can tell there's alcohol in here.
(bell ding)
- It's not bad, bad.
It's just not as good.
- And I can feel the
alcohol a little bit more.
I think because it's not a
sweet as the previous one.
- I would rather have this with a meal,
- Yea.
but I'd rather have the
fruity one at a party.
- The textures not as strong
so it's something that you could drink
in larger amounts instead of enjoy.
- This is not bad.
I'd pay for that.
- I recommend the Santa
Monica California Champagne.
- Yes.
- Because it is good.
But, the first one more for parties.
- It showed that there
were different options.
Some a bit more sweet.
Some a bit more dry.
- We wouldn't buy it.
We would only drink it if given to us.
- You can find good ones,
good American champagnes.
You can't expect it to
taste like French champagne.
(light music)